te atreverías a caminar desnudo por las
calles ante esta pregunta podrás decir
linda cómo crees estás loca tal vez
sientas mucho miedo tal vez mucha
vergüenza o tal vez te tiemblen las
piernitas como a mí me están temblando
en este momento o bueno tal vez sientas
muchísima emoción
ante esta pregunta bueno pues el día de
hoy quiero compartir té que es así como
he aprendido a caminar a lo largo de mi
vida como ya saben fui y gimnasta desde
pequeña la gimnasia es un deporte de
muchísima disciplina es un deporte en el
cual puedes aprender cosas muy muy
buenas pero también es un deporte
en el cual las gimnastas vivimos con
miedo esto es algo que
tal vez podrás pensar claro viven con
miedo con tales acrobacias que hacen tal
vez tienen miedo a golpearse a caerse es
obvio linda pero
yo no vengo a compartir que este tipo de
miedo el miedo que vivimos las gimnastas
a diario es el miedo a hablar
el miedo a hablar de injusticias de
abusos de golpes por parte de nuestros
entrenadores
y no podemos hablar simplemente porque
si hablamos by sueño nos hacen a un lado
del equipo nos corren
adiós
recuerdo una ocasión cuando era pequeña
me encontraba arriba de la viga de
equilibrio tenía mis brazos arriba y
desde arriba de la vida yo miraba como
mi entrenadora me veía
y ya estaba cansada de verme porque
porque yo tenía mucho miedo de hacer un
ejercicio que para mí era nuevo
ella ya estaba harta hasta que
finalmente la saque de quicio se me
acercó me jaló del cabello o como
vulgarmente dicen me jaló de las greñas
y me obligó a hacer el ejercicio
mientras me insultaba me golpeaba y me
amenazaba
me sentí realmente humillada esta fue la
primera ocasión en la cual sufrió un
abuso de este tipo
nunca le contesto a mis padres por miedo
no quería perder ese sueño
el miedo es un tipo de desnudez al cual
nos enfrentamos las gimnastas a diario
el miedo es un tipo de desnudez que
tenemos todos los seres humanos es
inevitable sin embargo visto desde otra
perspectiva el miedo puede ser
fantástico porque cuando te sacude si
decides lograr superarlo podrás haber
dado un paso a tu crecimiento
otro tipo de desnudez al cual nos
enfrentamos todos es la vergüenza creo
que a más de alguno nos ha pasado que
vamos caminando bien campantes por la
calle y de pronto tropezamos
y bueno ni se diga cuando tropezamos y
asustamos en el piso aunque nadie nos
haya visto volteamos a ver si
si alguien nos vio se siente mucha
vergüenza
bueno pues algo así sentía mis 16 años y
no fue del todo placentero
recuerdo que me encontraba terminando un
entrenamiento previo a panamericanos del
2011 en guadalajara y me dirigí a uno de
los cubículos para recibir una de mis
terapias físicas de costumbre
estando en los cubículos me encontraba
sola cuando de pronto uno de los
entrenadores aprovechó que me encontraba
sola
para abusar de mí
es muy complicado procesar esto cuando
viene por parte de alguien en quien tú
confías
la vergüenza te persigue como si
hubieras cometido el más grande de los
crímenes
en este día lo difícil que es hablarlo
con alguien más
sientes la angustia la pena la culpa
sientes que al salir a las calles todo
el mundo te está viendo sin que nadie lo
sepa
todas estas emociones me brillaron a
dejar la gimnasia
esto nunca nadie lo supo
la vergüenza es un tipo de desnudez que
nos puede hacer sentir culpables la
vergüenza es la sombra que nos dice que
algo hicimos mal que nos hemos
equivocado es una de las cosas más
difíciles con las que vivimos los seres
humanos
pero la vergüenza puede ser una gran
maestra que nos ayuda a quitarnos esa
venda de los ojos para demostrarnos lo
realmente valientes que somos
bueno como ya les comenté me retiré de
la gimnasia y empieza a vivir como una
persona normal y bueno como toda persona
normal que cree me enamoró por primera
vez
y yo me sentía en las nubes estaba tan
enamorada lo di todo me entregué
totalmente
pero
qué creen
vuelven a abusar de mí
esta vez a través de celos insultos
golpes maltrato
pero bueno yo aguantaba total ya estaba
acostumbrada había llevado una vida así
yo me encontraba en una época complicada
ya que estaba estudiando la universidad
y esta época se complicó aún más ya que
de forma no planeada
nos embaraza mos y mi pareja decide
abandonar mi
me encuentro sola embarazada y sin
pareja
las personas me empezaron a juzgar
que no era la niña buena la buena
gimnasta la promesa de mexico la mejor
estudiante
y siendo juzgada por las personas fue en
donde me descubrí desnuda
vulnerable me sentía sola y desprotegida
me sentía desnuda porque no sabía a
quién recurrir
me sentía desnuda porque la gente me
veía como una persona desordenada como
una persona promiscua como una fracasada
sin que ellos supieran lo que realmente
estaba viviendo
todos los días lloraba embarazada todos
los días me atormentaba todos los días
me decía cosas terribles a mí misma
todos los días me atacaba todos los días
hasta que al fin toque fondo
dije basta ya hasta aquí
cuando tocas fondo hay dedos
eres aplastado por la presión o tomas
impulso para salir a la superficie
fue ahí en donde me descubrí desnuda al
darme cuenta de mis miedos de mis
inseguridades de mi vulnerabilidad al
darme cuenta que ya no tenía
absolutamente nada que perder fue en
donde decidí cambiar mi chip
ya no me dejaría ser abusada de ninguna
manera ya no me dejaría sentir miedo ya
no me iba a quedar callada y es por eso
que el día de hoy estoy aquí
mi hijo es la bendición más grande que
tengo
él me ayudó a querer cambiar mi chip me
ayudó a cambiar mi vida
y así fue como me decidí a salir
adelante con la ayuda de dios
convirtiendo todas esas cosas negativas
y experiencias feas en aprendizaje y
crecimiento
que puedes aprender de un abuso
que puedes aprender de una relación
violenta que puedes aprender de un
fracaso y eso es lo que yo hice
encontrar lo que me hacía sentir desnuda
para entender
qué era lo que me hacía sentir así y
cambiarle el significado a mi desnudez
hay una historia que me gusta mucho
estaba un profesor en el aula de clases
y escribió lo siguiente
uno de los alumnos se percató que hubo
un error en la última operación y
comenzó a burlarse de este profesor
todos los compañeros vieron el error y
se burlaron en su cara el profesor
espero a que todos guardaran silencio
y dijo
yo cometí este error que era muy muy
obvio para demostrarles cómo es que se
comporta el mundo puedes acertar nueve
veces y nadie lo nota te equivocas un en
una ocasión y en eso se va a fijar la
gente
así es la vida
puedes acertar en todo y nadie lo va a
notar te equivocas una ocasión
y en eso se va a fijar la gente y eso
fue lo que a mí me pasó me equivoqué
entonces es donde yo decido al fin ser
yo misma
no buscar agradar a la gente el buscar
agradar a la gente me hizo mantenerme
callada tanto tiempo el buscar agradar a
la gente me hizo tener miedo me hizo no
ser yo misma
ahora soy yo misma me muestro como soy a
donde quiera que voy me muestro como soy
en mis redes sociales me muestro como
soy como mamá
no quiero aparentar tener algo que no
tengo o ser algo que no soy
sé tú mismo
gracias a que decidí
hacer esto es que logré estar en un
reality show deportivo logré tener mi
academia de gimnasia logré tener una
empresa de artículos deportivos gracias
a eso después de todo lo que me sucedió
logré eso
te voy a compartir una de las pocas
veces en las cuales fui yo misma
cuando era pequeña tenía una compañera
en la gimnasia que tenía un hermano que
era muy pero muy muy guapo a todas las
niñas nos gustaban nos encantaba y bueno
todas las niñas le decían a diario que
se lo presentaran excepto yo me daba
muchísima vergüenza era súper tímida
hasta que un día decidí ser yo misma y
me atreví a decirle que si me lo
presentaba y sabes cuál fue su respuesta
no va linda como crees pero ahorita no
está buscando novia
no sabes la vergüenza sentí muchísima
vergüenza pero ese día me decidí
a que algún día yo lo conocería por mis
propios medios y bueno así decidida fui
en todo en mi vida algún día voy a tener
voy a hacer la mejor gimnasta y lo logré
algún día voy a tener mis negocios ya
los tengo algún día voy a sanar esto que
tanto me duele algún día voy a conocer
al amor de mi vida
este es el chico del que les hable
y que creen
pero este chico es ahora mi prometido y
nos vamos a casar este año
tienes que saber lo que quieres y tienes
que estar decidido a vencer sus miedos
no tengas miedo de expresarte no tengas
miedo de ser tú mismo sé tú mismo
no tengas miedo de estar desnudo porque
cuando eres vulnerable realmente está
siendo más fuerte
cuando me invitaron a dar esta plática
creen que les compartiera mi experiencia
como mujer como mamá como emprendedora
como deportista sin embargo para mí era
aún más importante mostrarme ante
ustedes desnuda
acabas de verme desnuda
cuando te verás tú
muchas gracias